[Music]
welcome back
okay in the last lecture
the last two lectures actually we
derived the wave equation from scratch
from first principles for a guitar
string
and then we solved the wave equation
using separation of variables a super
powerful technique to solve partial
differential equations linear partial
differential equations
and we derived at this solution here
where uh the solution uh for the
displacement of that string kind of the
vertical position
uh as a function of space x and time
u of x and t
is the product of sines in space sine
waves in space that satisfy my boundary
condition with a period
n pi over l that satisfies the boundary
condition that my guitar string is
pinned
uh to be a length l
and a product of sines in x and cosines
in time and these cosines in time
essentially are what are causing the
string to oscillate
to
the amplitude of these sine waves to
oscillate in time which creates the
acoustic waves that you hear when you
play a guitar string
and at the very end of the second
lecture i showed you that using this
trigonometric identity here in pink
you can transform this solution which we
derived this kind of solution here
i'm having a really hard time with
stars today
you can transform this solution
into this very interesting form here
where now
we've kind of combined our spatial signs
and our temporal cosines
into these sines of x plus c t and x
minus c t
and so in general you can say that my u
of x comma t
if this equals some function
uh
let's call it some function f
of x you know plus ct
that is going to be a solution of this
pde
uh and if i had another one you know
plus
f of x minus ct that is also going to be
a solution
of this pde
so what i want to do in this lecture
there's kind of two or three things i
want to do first
i want to show you i want to give you
some intuition for what this means that
i can take my basic solution and write
it in terms of this function of x plus
ct plus a function of x minus ct what
does that mean what's the interpretation
i'm going to show you that these are in
fact solutions of the pde
and then i'm also going to show you how
this ties into something called the
method of characteristics which is a
visual way of plotting the solutions in
a space time diagram so really cool
stuff
and this ties in a lot with
you know advanced physics so if you
think about how shock waves form on a
fighter jet or on a missile or on a
bullet you're going to be using the
method of characteristics
and these xt diagrams
okay so let's jump in first off let's
just verify that f of x plus ct is a
solution of my partial differential
equation
so if i take uh let's say you know f um
maybe i'll do it over here i'm like i've
already boxed myself out
of space
so let's confirm
that
f
of x plus c t
is a solution
so first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to compute you know
the first the second partial derivative
with respect to time
and with respect to space
so you know f
t t
is just the partial of this with respect
to time twice so the first time i take
its derivative i'm going to get c times
f prime
the second time i'm going to get c
squared times f double prime
so this is c squared f
uh you know double prime
x plus c t
and f x x
is just
f double prime
and so i can verify that this is a
solution let me see if this is true um
is it true
that
u t t
which is f t t
so c squared f double prime
does that equal
c squared
f x x which is f double prime
yes these are equal to each other so
essentially if u equals f confirm that u
equals f
is a solution
the way i'm doing that is i'm i'm taking
both of the partial derivatives with
respect to time
and with respect to x
and i'm plugging them in to the left and
the right hand side of the equation so u
t t
is f t t it's this expression here c
squared f double prime
and that had better equals c squared
times u x x
but u x x is just f double prime
so
c squared f double prime equals
c squared
f x x or u x x which is c squared f
double prime so i've confirmed that this
is a solution for any function f
that you can name any
function you can name
that satisfies your boundary conditions
this is going to be a solution of u
uh let's just quickly verify the same is
true of f of x
minus c t in fact i think this is going
to be pretty trivial
because again the you know f
single derivative in t
is going to be you know minus c
f prime
but the second derivative f t t we
multiply it by another i'm just doing
the chain rule here i'm just saying you
know this is partial f
with respect to the argument times the
derivative of the inside which is minus
ct
uh and so this is c squared
f double prime
so again and f x x
is still
f double prime
and so again still we have c squared f
double prime which is
u t t equals c squared f double prime
equals
c squared times f x x which is c squared
times f double prime
so it doesn't matter
if i have the argument x plus ct or x
minus ct both of those are solutions of
of this partial differential equation
and maybe uh i'm going to take a break
from the guitar string for a minute i'm
just going to think of a general
wave problem where let's say i just have
i have some string
and
i am kind of shaking it and creating
some wave pattern that i'm then going to
like let go
maybe i have like a really really really
long guitar string so super duper long
guitar string uh maybe like a cable car
string something like that
so i've got you know it is under tension
at a very very long distance there is
some tension in the string
and then i have some initial shape i've
got some some arbitrary shape
uh kind of f
of x
at time zero okay so that's
this initial shape at time zero
what i'm going to claim is that as long
as this satisfies my boundary conditions
which if i have you know kind of this
thing attention
at a very very far distance away and i
create the shape f of x comma 0 that
eventually goes to 0 smoothly
on a compact domain
what's going to happen
is as
i you know let the system go and tension
starts to do its work of moving this
the solution
what's going to happen is this f of x
comma 0 is going to start traveling to
the right
and traveling to the left this is a
weird thing that happens in wave physics
is that f of x plus c t
and f of x minus c t are solutions
which means that
you know at
time
t
um
i want to think about this
if i just shift x over
by c t if i if i just shift this entire
thing over by c t
that is also a solution for my system at
time t and so what that means is that if
i if i come up with this
this x t diagram this space time diagram
so x is on the x axis
t is on the y axis
and i have my initial shape i'm just
going to draw it as like a little pulse
here
then what's going to happen immediately
is that waves traveling to the right
at speed c
are solutions of the partial
differential equation like a wave
traveling at the right like this is a
valid solution
and a wave traveling to the left at the
same speed is also a valid solution
so if i start with some initial
condition and then i let it go that
initial condition is basically going to
start propagating out at speed c both
left and right because these are each
solutions of my partial differential
equation
this is a very strange and interesting
property of this kind of hyperbolic
partial differential equation the wave
equation where information kind of
passes at a constant speed c
in this x-t diagram so this is really
important when you think about things
like shock waves and shockwave physics
you'll be drawing lots of these diagrams
of you know what things interact at what
times
now if i make an even simpler example
here and instead of having an infinite
string that goes in both directions
let's say i have a fixed
string
and i i hold one end of that string so i
hold one end of that string and i start
whipping it up and down
and i send a traveling wave through
this system so i whip it up and down and
i send a traveling wave to the right
now
i kill this left solution
because there is no x
that can go left basically my hand or
that wall is going to be a reflecting
boundary condition
and so i only get these solutions that
are passing to the right
uh in this xt diagram
and so uh
what's interesting is that there are
these regions
where essentially um
okay i always get confused so
at very large x's
yeah for very far away there are regions
here where information
hasn't propagated yet
hasn't
propagated
yet
okay and so that's kind of what we mean
by hyperbolic partial differential
equations are characterized by there
being regions of space and time where it
takes a certain amount of time for
information to propagate downstream this
is true in shockwave physics this is
true anytime you have a limiting speed
of sound or speed of light there will be
regions
in space where a disturbance will not
have reached that region yet
that's in contrast to things like
elliptic pdes and parabolic pdes where
you instantly
have information kind of traveling
across the entire domain so in laplace's
equation and in the heat equation if i
have a delta function of heat on a
rectangular square
one infinitesimal time unit later i will
feel the effects of that heat
everywhere on that plate
now um that's an approximation that's
that's that's a mathematical
approximation that goes into those
partial differential equations there
still is information
travel um you know in a heated plate but
the equation we use though that
information passes
instantaneously so this is the idea of
the method of characteristics these are
called characteristic lines the lines of
kind of the lines in the xt diagram that
travel at this wave speed c
so this thing literally has a slope
uh delta x
over delta t this slope would be
the constant c my wave speed how much x
i travel in a given amount of time
i guess technically this would be 1 over
c the way that i've drawn it in this you
could also draw it so x is vertical and
time goes to the right i've seen it lots
of different ways
but these these characteristic lines are
essentially lines where information
propagates in these linear wave equation
systems this is super important in
things like fiber optic communication
where you're sending a wave you know
through a medium
uh you know there is an information
propagation speed the speed of light
that determines
you know how information is passed along
those characteristics in an xt diagram
good and it's all because these
functions f of x minus ct and f of x
plus ct are both solutions of my my
partial differential equation
as long as f of x you know satisfied my
initial conditions uh and as long as my
boundary conditions are not somehow
violated
good so last thing i'm going to do is
just revisit the
guitar string where i have fixed
boundary conditions because i think this
one's kind of interesting
so i'm going to go back
to this xt diagram here
but now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to kind of um
mark that we know that at x equals 0 and
at x equals l
i have these pinned boundary conditions
so my guitar string is fixed at x equals
zero and x equals l
and so information can't pass past those
points it kind of reflects these are
reflecting boundary conditions so if i
have a wave
if i could you know on my guitar string
keep it flat and then have a little
disturbance and then let the string go
that disturbance is going to travel in
both directions until it hits the wall
and then start kind of ricocheting off
the wall
and so the way this looks is that if i
have a little disturbance here let's say
i have you know some disturbance here
maybe i i try to pluck the guitar string
to be like kind of like a little delta
function at that point it never is going
to be a default delta function it's
actually going to be a triangle
what's going to happen is that that wave
is going to travel left and right
until it starts bouncing
and ricocheting off of the wall
and as you notice here it's actually
going to eventually meet up at another
location presumably and then do it again
and you know it'll keep kind of bouncing
and moving around and super posing and
again because my
initial condition if i pluck my guitar
string it's really i'm making this very
shallow little triangle as my initial
condition
what you're going to expect to see is
that all of the sines and cosines that
make up this this uh this initial
condition this little triangular
displacement when i pluck the guitar
string
is that immediately all of the sines and
cosines are going to start traveling and
bouncing and ricocheting throughout this
fixed domain 0 to l they're all going to
start traveling and moving
and at some time t in the future they're
going to superimpose again i'm actually
assuming that they're going to
superimpose to a little
down triangle here and then at twice
that time they're going to
re-superimpose back to this initial
triangle again assuming there's no
damping there's no friction
so some really cool things can happen
these kind of you know bouncing
reflecting
traveling wave solutions but this is an
all all an outfall
of the fact that these x plus ct
and x minus ct solutions
uh are are also solutions of your
partial differential equation for this
constant wave speed c
okay that's just like a very very
shallow crash course on method of
characteristics
uh for this
this is sometimes called the two-way
wave equation because your waves can go
you know left and right in both ways two
ways the two-way wave equation
okay thank you